[Music]
[Applause]
hey
[Applause]
deep in the lands of zara the humans of
kupaki
struggle to stay alive as they are
attacked by the wicked drow elves of
larnia
darkness falls as the humans beg their
king to save them
a noble king known only as the grand
wizard
for a thousand years the battle has been
waged with only the bravery of the grand
wizard to protect his human followers
but even though the wizard king is so
undeniably cool the drow elf armies
continue their attacks
they seek the human's most treasured
relic the stick of truth
but the tides of war seem to change as
news of a new kid spreads throughout the
land
in order to save the humans the grand
wizard must get to the new cave
before the drow elves can manipulate his
name and use him
to take the sacred relic and human hands
for whomever controls the stick
controls the universe
[Applause]
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
well i think that's everything we did
we're
really moved in it's a new beginning for
us
things are finally going to be good do
you really think it will be better for
him
they won't look for him here you just
need to make sure he doesn't attract any
attention
come on come on let's see how he's doing
sweetie honey all dressed
hey champ how do you like your new room
i know it's a big change for all of us
but son
do you remember why we moved to this
quiet little mountain town
he doesn't remember he doesn't remember
at all that's good that's good he
doesn't remember
uh sweetie we want you to have lots of
fun here
why don't you go out and make some
friends right get outside and play son
like like normal kids we've got some
money for you on the kitchen counter
sweetie
just be back before it gets dark
yeah we love you too
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
go on outside go look around the
neighborhood
come on son get out there make friends
one
[Music]
it wasn't a request it was a command now
get out there and make some friends
you shall die by my war hammer drow elf
ah a better stay to the forest room
that way i banish you first haha you
can't hold out much longer
help somebody i can't hold out much
longer
hey no fair that's cheating i'm gonna
tell my mom
thanks kid i didn't realize he had a
health potion but
my name is butters the merciful i'm a
paladin i live right next door to you we
should be friends
[Music]
now that we're friends you should speak
with the wizard king he's been talking
about your arrival
the wizard lives this way in the
greenhouse over there
hey where are you from
where'd you live before moving here
do you like colorado
why are you wearing your hair like that
oh hill the grand wizard
so you are the new kid your coming was
foretold by coldwell banker
i am the wizard king but the time for
talk is not nad
let me show you my kingdom
now get ready oh who's your new friend
eric shut up mom not now
[Music]
don't talk to her she's not part of the
game
[Music]
welcome to the kingdom of koopa keep
our weapon shop here is tended by clyde
a level 14 warrior
here you can see our massive stables
overseen by the level 9 ranger
scott malkinson who has the power of
diabetes
and here of course is the breathtaking
and lovely princess kinney
the fairest maiden in all the kingdom
don't ask why kenny wanted to be a chick
it's just how he seems to be rolling
right now
you have been sought out new kid because
humans everywhere are in great danger
i need something from you and in return
i am prepared to allow you into my
kingdom
i know you are very excited it's time
for your first quest
but first please tell us thy name
[Music]
you entered douchebag is that correct
are you sure you want to keep the name
douchebag
very well douchebag you will now choose
a class fighter
mage thief or jew
a mage is like a wizard only not as cool
a fighter has courage honor and the
ability to kick [ __ ]
a mage is like a you look sneaky enough
to be a thief jew huh
so i guess we'll never really be friends
welcome to the kkk douchebag did you who
probably can also handle our finances
hooray now please go and visit the
weapon shop
procure yourself a weapon and we shall
teach you to fat
would you like to see my where's weary
traveler perhaps you would like to hear
tips and rumors for two dollars
don't let it bother you that there's a
game to be played
[Music]
ah a lovely purchase
new kid has checked out everything in my
backyard hardcore gamer
[Music]
[Music]
bye
ah you have procured a weapon yes it's
now time to teach you how to fight
i want you to take your new weapon and
with the bravery of a noble knight
beat up clad what kick clyde's ass new
kid what'd i do i'm the king clad and
the king wishes to be amused
go on new kid kick his ass
[Music]
i'm gonna kick your ass claude you have
to wait your turn
that's lame no cloud it's like olden
times you have to wait your turn like in
the middle ages chad
i know it's lame cloud but that's how
we're [ __ ] doing it all right
douchebag bash cloud's facing don't be
shy
come on fight
that all you got oh my god it's butters
all over again
okay look try putting your back into it
at the last possible moment
oh hell yeah clyde's your [ __ ] all
right clyde's wearing armor in order to
hurt him i want you to hit cloud as hard
as you can
[Music]
oh oh [ __ ] dude i think i see blood
[ __ ] nice brah that's exactly what
you do to guys with armor like that
okay listen up the key to surviving in
battle is not to get hit in the boughs
clad it's your turn to attack douchebag
protect your bout
prepare yourself this is unblockable
no no i said protect protect your bouts
no that's not blocking that's sucking
try again
yeah that's what i'm talking about dude
you're already way better than clyde
all right it's time to use your heroic
powers using your ability takes power
points or pp for short
peepee if you have a [ __ ] better name
for them then [ __ ] say it clyde
[ __ ] [ __ ] i'm the king and i say
it's pp
douchebag use your jew ability to make
cloud pay for insulting the king
sick way to wipe that smile off his
stupid face douchebag
now do it one more time finish him what
i was going easy
take this this does double damage
[Music]
i dodged that
dude that was awesome you were all like
peanut clappers
[Music]
okay okay you proved yourself worthy
douchebag now come inside the war tent
and i shall let you see the relic
well here it is the reason why humans
and elves are locked in a never-ending
war
the relic for which human and elf are
willing to die
the stick of truth
just two days ago we took the stick back
from the elves our kingdom was dying but
now it's raz
for whoever controls the stick controls
the universe
don't gaze at it too long for its power
is too much for mere motors to look at
now that you have seen the stick of
truth let's discuss your dues being a
member of my kingdom cost 9.95 for the
first week
four dollars of which is tax deductible
someone who sounded the alarm and i'm
alone alone what is it
the elves were attacking oh my god
defensive positions
douchebag come help us
[Music]
man the gate don't let them through give
us the stick humans
[ __ ] you drow elf come and get it clad
guard the stick of truth while we defend
the fortress aye aye aye
aye we're not playing pirates clyde
douchebag this is your chance to prove
yourself
hold off the [ __ ] elves at all costs
[ __ ] you [ __ ] son of a biscuit
meanie
do it douchebag kick these off asses
[Applause]
your wounded douchebag potions will heal
you here
[Music]
the rules say you can have one post in
every turn i asked for five but this was
a compromise
this guy's fast douchebag try to block
all these attacks
in your face
well if this job doesn't work out at
least you've got a future of the
training dummy come on get it right
suck my balls okay if you block all the
attacks you get a counter attack
look at your enemy on the ground weak
and helpless kick the [ __ ] out of him
awesome you kicked his helpless ass now
finish off these elves in the name of
the wizard king
ah
[Music]
stop [ __ ] around
great job douchebag
[Music]
where the hell
you got this douchebag [ __ ]
eat [ __ ] what are you waiting for
douchebag that guy's just standing there
go kick his ass
[Music]
oh man he was totally waiting for you
dude you can't just hit him like that
[Music]
you need to try a different tactic to
damage him look at that archer hiding
behind his friend like a wood
switch to your arrows douchebag snipe
that little [ __ ]
sweet now you can hit the guy in the
back go for the pink mitt
[Music]
yeah [ __ ] that's what you get for
[ __ ] with the wizard king
careful douchebag that guy's ready for
your arrows now you gotta try something
else
[Music]
come on fight
[Applause]
great job douchebag
thanks bye to the last man
[Music]
let's do this douchebag
[Music]
okay that guy has a shield shields are
super weak just hit them with your
simplest hit over and over to wear them
down quickly
[Music]
hell yeah that's how you do it the other
elf let his guard down now's your chance
power attack is armor
oh that's it now finish him
drow elves fall back fall back i say
yes awesome dude take that you [ __ ]
elves
better luck next time we still control
the universe
it's gone what the stick of truth the
elves got it
that was your one goddamn job clyde to
guard the stick of [ __ ] truth
clyde you are hereby banished from space
and time
what no you can't do that yeah i can
you're banished and lost in time and
space yeah go home claude
you fought bravely on the battlefield
douchebag yeah this new kid may be a
juice bag like he sure can fight
shut up scott nobody cares what you
think anyways we have a bigger problem
now
the stick of truth has been stolen and
we must assemble our entire army in
order to get it back but our three best
warriors still haven't reported for duty
my king
our newest member can take care of that
douchebag i want you to go out into the
neighborhood and find my greatest
warriors
token tweak and craig i'm texting their
pictures to your personal inventory
device now
but beware the lands outside are full of
marauding drow elves monsters and sixth
graders
be sure you're well equipped now go and
send my warriors here buttons go with
him